It's been four years since I first learned about the disappearance of Neyam May, an 18-year-old who went missing from the small New South Wales town of Batlow back in 2002. I don't know if it's because Neyam and I finished high school in the same year or we shared a similar taste in music, but I felt instinctively drawn to her story. As I learned more about Neyem's story, the revelations that unfolded left me in shock. The result is Missing Neyem, the latest 12-part series from Casefile Presents. Researched and hosted by me, the series features exclusive interviews with key players who help us dive into the details of Neyem's case as we go back to Batlo to try and make sense of what really happened.
距离我第一次听说内亚姆·梅（Neyam May）失踪的消息已经过去四年了，那年她18岁，于2002年在新南威尔士州的小镇巴特洛（Batlow）失踪。我不知道是因为我和内亚姆在同一年高中毕业，还是因为我们有着相似的音乐品味，但我本能地被她的故事所吸引。随着我对内亚姆故事的深入了解，随之而来的真相让我感到震惊。最终呈现出的就是《寻找内亚姆》（Missing Neyem），这是Casefile Presents推出的最新12集系列节目。该系列由我进行研究并担任主持，通过对关键人物的独家采访，带我们深入了解内亚姆案件的细节，并重返巴特洛，试图弄清当年究竟发生了什么。
The entire 12-part series will be available on September 24. Stay tuned to the end of today's episode to hear the trailer. Our episodes deal with serious and often distressing incidents. If you feel at any time you need support, please contact your local crisis centre. For suggested phone numbers for confidential support and for a more detailed list of content warnings, please see the show notes for this episode on your app or on our website. Today's episode involves crimes against children and won't be suitable for all listeners. The Northwest Providence Channel is a body of water that sits between the two banks that make up most of the Bahama Archipelago. To the west of the channel is the Gulf Stream, an ocean current that flows through the Straits of Florida and up along the east coast of the United States.
全长12集的系列节目将于9月24日上线。请收听今天节目的结尾，届时将播放预告片。我们的节目涉及严重且往往令人痛苦的事件。如果您在任何时候感到需要支持，请联系您当地的危机中心。如需获取保密支持的建议电话号码以及更详细的内容警告列表，请查看您应用内或我们网站上本期节目的节目说明。今天的节目涉及针对儿童的犯罪，并不适合所有听众。西北普罗维登斯海峡（Northwest Providence Channel）是一片位于巴哈马群岛大部分地区所构成的两岸之间的水域。海峡以西是墨西哥湾流（Gulf Stream），这是一股流经佛罗里达海峡并沿美国东海岸北上的洋流。
On Monday November 13 1961, a 21,000 tonne oil tanker called the Gulf Lion entered the northwest Providence channel after departing the Florida city of Fort Lauderdale, headed for San Juan, Puerto Rico. At noon that day, one of the crew members assumed the role of the tanker's lookout at the stern. About 30 minutes into his four hour shift, he noticed something bobbing in the choppy water about four miles away. It was a white wooden dinghy with its sails furled. Inside the small boat was a lone vacation. A successful contact lens optometrist who resided in Green Bay, Wisconsin, Arthur had
1961年11月13日星期一，一艘名为“海湾狮号”（Gulf Lion）的2.1万吨油轮在离开佛罗里达州劳德代尔堡市前往波多黎各圣胡安的途中，进入了西北普罗维登斯海峡。当天中午，一名船员在船尾担任瞭望员。在他四小时轮班开始约30分钟后，他注意到四英里外波涛汹涌的水面上有什么东西在起伏。那是一艘帆布收起的白色木制小艇。小艇里有一个孤独的度假者。亚瑟（Arthur）是一位居住在威斯康星州绿湾的成功隐形眼镜验光师，他
previously served in the US Navy. On his way to serve in Myanmar during World War II, he had sailed across the Pacific Ocean and developed a deep love of the sea and the tropics. The climate was far warmer than in his home state of Wisconsin, and the expansive Pacific was far greater than any body of water he'd seen before. After completing his military service, Arthur met a woman two years his junior named Jean Brosh. The two had a whirlwind romance and married shortly after meeting. The couple soon had three children, a son named Brian and two daughters, Terry Jo and Renee. Over the following years,
曾在美国海军服役。在二战期间前往缅甸服役的途中，他曾横渡太平洋，并对海洋和热带地区产生了深厚的感情。那里的气候比他的家乡威斯康星州温暖得多，广阔的太平洋也比他以前见过的任何水域都要大。退役后，亚瑟遇到了一位比他小两岁的女性，名叫简·布罗什（Jean Brosh）。两人坠入爱河，相识不久后便结婚了。这对夫妇很快有了三个孩子，一个儿子名叫布莱恩（Brian），两个女儿分别是特里·乔（Terry Jo）和蕾妮（Renee）。在接下来的几年里，
Arthur often dreamt of showing his family the tropic waters that he'd loved so much. By late 1961, that dream finally became a reality. Arthur and Jean had saved their money and planned to escape Wisconsin's cold winter for a sailing adventure. It would start with a week-long cruise in the Bahamas, and if that went well, the family would take a year-long sabbatical together. The family would take a year-long sabbatical together. In early November 1961, the Duperrault family road-tripped down to Florida and began looking for the right boat to charter at the city's Bahiamar Marina. Arthur Duperrault inspected a number of boats docked at the marina before discovering the Bluebell, a two-masted sailboat known as a Catch that had originally
亚瑟经常梦想着带家人去看看他深爱的热带水域。到1961年底，这个梦想终于成为了现实。亚瑟和简攒下了钱，计划逃离威斯康星州的寒冬，去进行一次航海探险。行程将从巴哈马为期一周的巡游开始，如果一切顺利，全家人将一起休一年的长假。全家人将一起休一年的长假。1961年11月初，杜佩罗（Duperrault）一家开车前往佛罗里达，开始在当地的巴哈马码头（Bahiamar Marina）寻找合适的租赁船只。亚瑟·杜佩罗检查了码头上停泊的多艘船只，最终发现了“蓝铃号”（Bluebell），这是一艘双桅帆船，被称为“双桅小帆船”（Ketch），最初
been built as a racing yacht. It was 60 feet long and 15 feet across at its widest point. It also had a wooden dinghy and black rubber life raft. Inside, the boat's main cabin was 13 feet long, with three portholes on either side and a skylight. The cabin contained a dining area with comfortable seating, a small bathroom, and a kitchenette. In front of the cabin was a main bedroom with a queen-sized bed. Another small sleeping area sat at the cabin's rear. These would be the family's quarters. Finally,
是作为赛艇建造的。它长60英尺，最宽处为15英尺。船上还有一艘木制小艇和一个黑色橡胶救生筏。船内的主舱长13英尺，两侧各有三个舷窗，顶部有一个天窗。船舱内设有一个带舒适座椅的用餐区、一个小浴室和一个小厨房。船舱前方是主卧室，配有一张大号双人床。船舱后部还有另一个小睡眠区。这些就是家人的住处。最后，
there was a forward cabin tucked in front of the main bedroom designed to house the boat's crew. Bluebell was the perfect size for the Dupereau family. Arthur found out it was owned by a man named Harold Pegg and skippered by a 44-year-old former Air Force pilot called Julian Harvey. Harold agreed to allow the Duper Alts to chart a bluebell for $100 per day. While the Duper Alts would help out here and there with some minor running and steering of the sailboat, Captain Julian Harvey would take the helm as their skipper. Captain Harvey had recently married just three months earlier, and his wife Mary, who was 34, would be the family's cook. By the afternoon of Wednesday November 8, the group was ready to set sail.
主卧室前方还有一个专门为船员设计的船头舱。“蓝铃号”的大小对杜佩罗一家来说非常完美。亚瑟发现这艘船的主人是一个名叫哈罗德·佩格（Harold Pegg）的人，船长是一位44岁的前空军飞行员，名叫朱利安·哈维（Julian Harvey）。哈罗德同意以每天100美元的价格将“蓝铃号”租给杜佩罗一家。虽然杜佩罗一家会偶尔帮忙进行一些简单的航行和掌舵工作，但朱利安·哈维船长将作为他们的船长掌舵。哈维船长在三个月前刚结婚，他34岁的妻子玛丽（Mary）将担任全家的厨师。到11月8日星期三下午，一行人准备启航。
The group was ready to set sail. Over the next few days, the Duparults and their crew spent their time cruising across the sea. They observed pelicans soaring through the sky, watched porpoises swim alongside their boat, and even spotted a giant sea turtle floating nearby. The children got a thrill when they saw a shark finned surface at one point. The family also visited a number of the Bahamas islands, most of which were tiny and uninhabited. All strong swimmers, the family went snorkeling and spearfishing. Sometimes Arthur went out in the dinghy with 14-year-old Brian and 11-year-old Terry Joe, and they would explore the coral reefs.
一行人准备启航。在接下来的几天里，杜佩罗一家和他们的船员在海上航行。他们观察着在天空中翱翔的鹈鹕，看着海豚在船边游动，甚至还发现了一只巨大的海龟在附近漂浮。当孩子们看到鲨鱼鳍浮出水面时，感到非常兴奋。这家人还参观了巴哈马群岛的多个岛屿，其中大多数岛屿都很小且无人居住。全家人都是游泳健将，他们去浮潜和用鱼叉捕鱼。有时亚瑟会带着14岁的布莱恩和11岁的特里·乔乘小艇出去，探索珊瑚礁。
Meanwhile, Jean Dupereault stayed on the beach with their youngest child, 7-year-old Renee, collecting shells and digging in the sand. Brian had brought a.22 calibre rifle along with the intention of possibly hunting sharks, but didn't end up using it. Meanwhile, Captain Harvey focused on the running of the ship, picking up supplies and assisting in filing paperwork that allowed the family to move freely through the Bahamas. His wife Mary didn't find the voyages carefree as the Duparoltz did. In a letter she sent home to her mother, she complained about never having a moment to herself, writing, I think I'll devise some kind of disappearing act. Why oh why can't people leave me alone?
与此同时，简·杜佩罗则和他们最小的孩子、7岁的蕾妮留在沙滩上，收集贝壳并在沙子里挖掘。布莱恩带了一支.22口径的步枪，打算用来猎鲨，但最终没用上。与此同时，哈维船长专注于船舶的运营，负责采购补给并协助办理让这家人在巴哈马自由通行的文书工作。他的妻子玛丽并不像杜佩罗一家那样觉得航行无忧无虑。在写给母亲的一封信中，她抱怨说自己从没有独处的时间，写道：“我想我得想出某种消失的戏法。为什么，为什么人们就不能让我一个人待着呢？”
But aside from this minor complaint, Mary seemed up a beat, telling her mother the Dupar Alts were lovely people and their children were well behaved. A few days into the trip, Captain Harvey anchored the Bluebell in the harbour of Sandy Point, a small fishing town in the great Abaco Bahamas. Over the course of a weekend, the Duparolts explored the village and chatted to locals, with Arthur Duparolt telling the village commissioner, "...this has been a once-in-a-lifetime vacation. We are going to come back and use Sandy Point as a winter resort." On Sunday November 12, Captain Harvey and his wife Mary headed to the Commissioner's office to file the family's leaving papers, as they would be beginning their journey
但除了这个小小的抱怨外，玛丽看起来情绪高涨，告诉母亲杜佩罗一家人很好，孩子们也很乖。航行几天后，哈维船长将“蓝铃号”停泊在巴哈马大阿巴科岛（Great Abaco）的一个小渔镇桑迪角（Sandy Point）的港口。周末期间，杜佩罗一家探索了村庄并与当地人聊天，亚瑟·杜佩罗告诉村专员：“……这是一次千载难逢的假期。我们打算回来，把桑迪角当作度假胜地。”11月12日星期日，哈维船长和妻子玛丽前往专员办公室提交这家人的离境文件，因为他们当晚就要开始
back to Florida that night. It was a 200 mile journey which Captain Harvey and Arthur Duparot planned to cover in two days by sailing almost constantly. They chatted and joked with the Commissioner and his wife. Mary told them that the Duparolts had already decided to charter the Bluebell again before Christmas, so they would all be back very soon. At 12.35pm the following day of Monday November 13, a crew member on board the oil tanker Gulf Lion spotted a small white dinghy bobbing in the choppy waters of the northwest Providence Channel. The figure of a man was visible inside the dinghy.
返回佛罗里达的旅程。这是一段200英里的航程，哈维船长和亚瑟·杜佩罗计划通过几乎不间断的航行在两天内完成。他们与专员及其妻子聊天开玩笑。玛丽告诉他们，杜佩罗一家已经决定在圣诞节前再次租用“蓝铃号”，所以他们很快就会回来。第二天，即11月13日星期一中午12点35分，“海湾狮号”油轮上的一名船员在西北普罗维登斯海峡波涛汹涌的水面上发现了一艘白色小艇在起伏。小艇里可以看到一个人的身影。
As the dinghy was behind the tanker, they had to turn around to head towards it. As the golf lion drew closer, its crew members saw the man stand and start to wave his arms, as though trying to get their attention. He appeared to have something in his arms, like a tarpaulin or life jacket, that he used to gesture with. They could also make out a black rubber life raft tied alongside the dinghy with something inside, though they couldn't see what the object was. Finally, after about 30 minutes, the tanker reached the dinghy. The man inside looked to be in his forties and was tall with bare feet and some bleached hair. Stammering slightly, he called out, My name is Julian Harvey. I am master of the Blue Bull. I have a dead baby on this dinghy.
由于小艇在油轮后方，他们不得不掉头驶向它。“海湾狮号”靠近时，船员们看到那个人站起来开始挥动手臂，似乎在试图引起他们的注意。他怀里似乎抱着什么东西，像是一块防水布或救生衣，用来打手势。他们还能辨认出小艇旁边系着一个黑色橡胶救生筏，里面有东西，尽管他们看不清那是什么。终于，在大约30分钟后，油轮到达了小艇旁。艇内的人看起来四十多岁，身材高大，赤着脚，头发有些发白。他结结巴巴地喊道：“我叫朱利安·哈维。我是‘蓝铃号’的船长。我的小艇上有一个死去的婴儿。”
It wasn't until the Gulf Lion had reached the dinghy that its crew members could finally see the object inside the life raft. It was the body of seven-year-old Renee Duperold. The sight of the little girl's body left the Gulf Lion's crew members feeling sick. Renee appeared stiff and blue and was clearly deceased. They lowered a basket to retrieve her body. After Renée was safely aboard the oil tanker, Captain Harvey clambered up a rope ladder to the golf lion's deck where crew members gathered around him. They provided him with food and treated him for
直到“海湾狮号”到达小艇旁，船员们才终于看清救生筏里的物体。那是七岁的蕾妮·杜佩罗的尸体。看到小女孩的尸体，让“海湾狮号”的船员们感到一阵恶心。蕾妮看起来身体僵硬，脸色发青，显然已经死亡。他们放下篮子将她的尸体打捞上来。在蕾妮被安全带上油轮后，哈维船长顺着绳梯爬上了“海湾狮号”的甲板，船员们围在他身边。他们为他提供了食物，并对他进行了
mild shock. Harvey appeared dazed as he was approached by the golf lion's captain, who asked him what had happened. Harvey explained that just before midnight the previous night, the bluebell had been sailing smoothly when it was suddenly caught up in a sharp gust of wind known as a squall. This resulted in the catcher's main mast snapping in two. A 50-foot portion of the mast plunged down, driving a huge hole into the Bluebell's deck and hole. As the main mast fell, it pulled the other mast down too, which fell into the cockpit over the engine room. Most of the Bluebell's passengers were gathered in the cockpit at the time and were now trapped by the mast's cables and rigging. Captain Harvey ran below deck to
轻度休克的治疗。当“海湾狮号”的船长走近询问发生了什么事时，哈维显得神情恍惚。哈维解释说，前一天午夜前不久，“蓝铃号”正在平稳航行，突然遭遇了一阵被称为“飑”（squall）的强风。这导致双桅小帆船的主桅杆断成两截。一段50英尺长的桅杆坠落，在“蓝铃号”的甲板和船体上砸出了一个大洞。主桅杆倒下时，也拉倒了另一根桅杆，它落在了机舱上方的驾驶舱里。“蓝铃号”的大多数乘客当时都聚集在驾驶舱里，被桅杆的缆绳和索具困住了。哈维船长跑下甲板去
fetch some cable cutters he could use to free the other passengers from the debris. deck to fetch some cable cutters he could use to free the other passengers from the debris. When he returned with them, he saw a fire raging. The second mast's fall had ruptured fuel lines in the engine room, resulting in enormous flames. The fire enveloped the cockpit and spread across the deck, which had recently been painted with highly flammable neoprene. Simultaneously, the catch had started to sink. Harvey returned below deck once again to grab a fire extinguisher, then tried to douse the flames, but they were too strong. Cut off from the other passengers by the blaze, Harvey decided to launch the dinghy and attempt to reach them by water instead. He used the cable cutters to cut through
拿一些缆绳切割器，用来把其他乘客从残骸中解救出来。当他拿着切割器回来时，看到火势正在蔓延。第二根桅杆的倒下弄断了机舱里的燃油管，导致了巨大的火焰。大火吞没了驾驶舱，并蔓延到甲板上，甲板最近刚涂过高度易燃的氯丁橡胶。与此同时，这艘双桅小帆船开始下沉。哈维再次回到甲板下拿灭火器，试图扑灭火焰，但火势太猛了。由于被大火与乘客隔开，哈维决定放下小艇，试图从水路接近他们。他用缆绳切割器切断了
a guardrail and release a life raft, then pushed the 10-foot long dinghy into the water. As he paddled towards the Bluebell's stern, the ketch began to sink faster, slipping below the rough waters. Captain Harvey navigated through the dark sea as best as he could, calling out to his wife Mary and the Dupereault family. But no one called back to him. The only passenger he was able to find was seven-year-old René Duparolt, who floated by him wearing a life preserver. When he pulled her into the life raft, she was already Case file will be back shortly. Thank you for supporting us by listening to this episode's sponsors. Let's be honest, recovering after a night of drinking isn't as easy as it used to be.
护栏并释放了一个救生筏，然后将10英尺长的小艇推入水中。当他划向“蓝铃号”船尾时，小帆船开始下沉得更快，滑入波涛汹涌的水面之下。哈维船长尽可能地在黑暗的海面上航行，呼喊着他的妻子玛丽和杜佩罗一家。但没有人回应他。他唯一能找到的乘客是7岁的蕾妮·杜佩罗，她穿着救生衣漂浮在他身边。当他把她拉上救生筏时，她已经……Casefile节目稍后回来。感谢您通过收听本期节目的赞助商来支持我们。老实说，宿醉后的恢复不像以前那么容易了。
Personally, I've noticed I don't recover as quickly as before. I always felt like I had to choose between enjoying my night out or feeling good the next day. That was until I discovered Z-Biotics Pre-Alcohol. Z-Biotics Pre-Alcohol Probiotic Drink is the world's first genetically engineered probiotic. drink is the world's first genetically engineered probiotic. It was invented by PhD scientists to tackle rough mornings after drinking. Here's how it works. When you drink, alcohol gets converted into a toxic byproduct in the gut. It's this byproduct, not dehydration, that's to blame for your rough next day. Pre-alcohol produces an enzyme to break this byproduct down. Just remember to make Z-Biotics your first drink of the night, drink responsibly, and
就我个人而言，我发现我的恢复速度不如以前了。我总觉得必须在享受夜晚和第二天感觉良好之间做出选择。直到我发现了Z-Biotics Pre-Alcohol。Z-Biotics Pre-Alcohol益生菌饮料是世界上第一款基因工程益生菌饮料。它是由博士科学家发明的，旨在解决饮酒后难受的早晨。它的工作原理如下：当你喝酒时，酒精会在肠道中转化为一种有毒的副产品。正是这种副产品，而不是脱水，导致了你第二天难受。Pre-Alcohol产生一种酶来分解这种副产品。只要记得把Z-Biotics作为你当晚的第一杯酒，负责任地饮酒，
you'll feel your best tomorrow. Olivia LaVoice, host of the Casefile Presents series The Bakersfield 3, uses pre-alcohol before a night out. With pre-alcohol, Olivia knows she will feel good the next morning and can confidently plan her next day activities, including working on her next Casefile Presents release. Go to zbiotics.com slash casefile to learn more and to get 15% off your first order when you use Casefile at checkout. ZBiotics is backed with 100% money back guarantee so if you're unsatisfied for any reason, they'll refund your money, no questions asked. Remember to head to zbiotics.com
你明天就会感觉最好。Casefile Presents系列节目《贝克斯菲尔德3》（The Bakersfield 3）的主持人奥利维亚·拉沃伊斯（Olivia LaVoice）在晚上外出前会使用Pre-Alcohol。有了Pre-Alcohol，奥利维亚知道她第二天早上会感觉良好，并能自信地计划第二天的活动，包括制作她的下一个Casefile Presents节目。前往zbiotics.com/casefile了解更多信息，并在结账时使用Casefile即可享受首单8.5折优惠。ZBiotics提供100%退款保证，所以如果您因任何原因不满意，他们会退还您的钱，不问任何问题。记得前往zbiotics.com
slash casefile and use the code CASEFILE at checkout for 15% off. I enjoy a good deal as much as anyone, but I'm not about to jump through flaming hoops just to save a few dollars. It needs to be simple, no hassles, no nonsense. So when Mint Mobile claimed I could get wireless for $15 a month with a 3 month plan, I was skeptical. But, it turns out it really is that simple. From their user-friendly website to the quick and easy activation process, switching to Mint Mobile is a breeze.
/casefile并在结账时使用代码CASEFILE享受8.5折优惠。我和其他人一样喜欢划算的交易，但我不会为了省几块钱而去跳火圈。它需要简单、无麻烦、不废话。所以当Mint Mobile声称我可以通过3个月的套餐以每月15美元的价格获得无线服务时，我是持怀疑态度的。但是，事实证明它确实就是这么简单。从他们用户友好的网站到快速简便的激活过程，切换到Mint Mobile简直是轻而易举。
The hardest part will be waiting on hold to cut ties with your old provider. To get started, head over to mintmobile.com slash case file. There you'll see that right now you can get any three month plan, including the unlimited plan, for just $15 a month. All plans come with high speed data, unlimited talk and text, and are delivered on the nation's largest 5G network. Plus, you can keep your own phone and bring your existing number and contacts. To get this new customer offer and your new 3-month premium wireless plan for just $15 a month, go to mintmobile.com slash casefile. That's mintmobile.com slash case file. That's mintmobile.com slash case file.
最困难的部分将是等待与你旧的供应商断绝关系。要开始使用，请前往mintmobile.com/casefile。在那里你会看到，现在你可以以每月仅15美元的价格获得任何三个月的套餐，包括无限流量套餐。所有套餐都附带高速数据、无限通话和短信，并由全国最大的5G网络提供支持。此外，你可以保留自己的手机，并带上现有的号码和联系人。要获得此新客户优惠并以每月仅15美元的价格获得新的3个月高级无线套餐，请前往mintmobile.com/casefile。网址是mintmobile.com/casefile。网址是mintmobile.com/casefile。
Cut your wireless bill to 15 bucks a month at mintmobile.com slash case file. $45 upfront payment required, equivalent to $15 per month. New customers on first three-month plan only. Speeds slower above 40GB on unlimited plan. Additional taxes, fees and restrictions apply. See Mint Mobile for details. Thank you for listening to this episode's ads. By supporting our sponsors, you support Casefile to continue to deliver quality content.
在mintmobile.com/casefile将您的无线账单削减至每月15美元。需要预付45美元，相当于每月15美元。仅限首次购买三个月套餐的新客户。无限套餐超过40GB后速度会变慢。适用额外的税费和限制。详情请咨询Mint Mobile。感谢您收听本期节目的广告。通过支持我们的赞助商，您支持Casefile继续提供优质内容。
The Gulf Lines captain radioed the US Coast Guard to alert them of the tragedy, and an air and sea search was launched to look for any possible survivors. Two rescue planes and two Coast Guard cutters were dispatched and messages were sent to ships in the area. Yet no survivors were found. Meanwhile, the Gulf Lion detoured to Nassau, the largest city in the Bahamas situated about 60 miles south of their current location to drop off Harvey. Miraculously, the Bluebells captain was uninjured and unharmed, but he had still suffered a severe trauma. The golf lions crew rallied together to raise $180 to give to Harvey. He used the collection to fly home to the United States, boarding a flight to Miami on Tuesday November 14. Upon landing in Miami, Captain Harvey phoned the Coast Guard to
“海湾狮号”船长通过无线电向美国海岸警卫队通报了这一悲剧，随后展开了海空搜救，寻找任何可能的幸存者。两架救援飞机和两艘海岸警卫队快艇被派往现场，并向该地区的船只发送了消息。然而，没有发现任何幸存者。与此同时，“海湾狮号”绕道前往巴哈马最大的城市拿骚（Nassau），该市位于他们当前位置以南约60英里处，以便放下哈维。奇迹般的是，“蓝铃号”的船长没有受伤，但他仍然遭受了严重的创伤。“海湾狮号”的船员们团结起来筹集了180美元给哈维。他用这笔钱飞回美国，于11月14日星期二登上了飞往迈阿密的航班。抵达迈阿密后，哈维船长致电海岸警卫队
check in with them. They asked Harvey to attend an informal hearing in two days' time so he could describe the events surrounding the Bluebell sinking in more detail. Harvey readily agreed and presented at the Coast Guard's Miami headquarters at 9am on Thursday November 16. Also in attendance was Harold Pegg, the owner of the Bluebell, Pegg's attorney, and investigating officer Lieutenant Ernest Murdoch. Before the hearing got underway, Harvey asked Lieutenant Murdoch whether there was any update in the search for the Bluebell's passengers. He was informed that not only had the two search planes and two Coast Guard cutters failed to find any
与他们联系。他们要求哈维在两天后参加一场非正式听证会，以便他能更详细地描述“蓝铃号”沉没前后的事件。哈维欣然同意，并于11月16日星期四上午9点出现在海岸警卫队迈阿密总部。出席会议的还有“蓝铃号”的所有者哈罗德·佩格、佩格的律师以及调查官欧内斯特·默多克（Ernest Murdoch）中尉。听证会开始前，哈维询问默多克中尉是否有关于搜寻“蓝铃号”乘客的最新消息。他被告知，不仅两架搜救飞机和两艘海岸警卫队快艇没能找到任何
who'd been on board the Bluebell, but they hadn't even recovered any debris from the catch. but they hadn't even recovered any debris from the catch. Captain Harvey began recounting what happened by explaining that the bluebell had departed Sandy Point shortly after dark on the evening of Sunday November 12. The weather had been pleasant and calm, prompting all of the passengers to stay up in the cockpit. The adults chatted while the duper old children napped. Captain Harvey was steering the boat. However, there were a few small rain squalls in the area and the Bluebell suddenly encountered one of these shortly before midnight. Harvey explained how this had broken the masts and severely damaged the boat.
在“蓝铃号”上的人，甚至连这艘双桅小帆船的任何残骸都没有打捞到。哈维船长开始讲述发生的事情，解释说“蓝铃号”是在11月12日星期日傍晚天黑后不久离开桑迪角的。天气一直很宜人且平静，促使所有乘客都待在驾驶舱里。大人们聊天，杜佩罗家的孩子们在打盹。哈维船长在掌舵。然而，该地区有几阵小雨，午夜前不久，“蓝铃号”突然遇到了其中一阵。哈维解释了这阵风是如何折断桅杆并严重损坏船只的。
broken the masts and severely damaged the boat. Some suffered injuries caused by the mast falling. Harvey's wife, Mary, and Arthur Dupereault both had their legs cut by splinters of wood. The accident caused 11-year-old Terry Jo Dupereault to start screaming, and Harvey had tried to calm her down. He stammered as he spoke and his jaw trembled. It was clear he was struggling at times to find the right words to describe the tragedy. Sometimes he shifted in his seat and ran his hands through his hair. Everyone present could see how much stress he was under. Harvey continued on, describing the fire and how the catch started to sink. Harvey said that as he decided to launch the dinghy, the passengers cut off from him by the fire saw what he was doing and chose to jump overboard into the water. All three duper old children had been
折断桅杆并严重损坏船只。一些人因桅杆倒下而受伤。哈维的妻子玛丽和亚瑟·杜佩罗的腿都被木屑割伤了。事故导致11岁的特里·乔·杜佩罗开始尖叫，哈维试图让她安静下来。他说话时结结巴巴，下巴颤抖。很明显，他有时很难找到合适的词汇来描述这场悲剧。有时他在座位上挪动，用手抓头发。在场的所有人都看得出他承受着多大的压力。哈维继续描述火灾以及这艘双桅小帆船是如何开始下沉的。哈维说，当他决定放下小艇时，被大火与他隔开的乘客看到了他的举动，并选择跳入水中。所有三个杜佩罗家的孩子当时都
wearing life preservers at the time. There were also life rings nearby that the adults had access to. They seemingly hoped to survive by escaping the flames and landing safely where Harvey could reach them. As Harvey steered the dinghy into the sea, he could hear the others yelling out faintly. But by the time he reached the stern they had leapt from, none were visible in the water. The pitch black night made Harvey's rescue mission even harder as he struggled to see his surroundings with rain, wind, and waves pelting his face. Harvey shouted to the others until his voice was hoarse. No replies came. The bluebell sank quietly into the sea, extinguishing the flames. When Harvey finally came across the
穿着救生衣。附近还有大人们可以使用的救生圈。他们似乎希望通过逃离火焰并安全着陆来生存，这样哈维就能找到他们。当哈维驾驶小艇进入大海时，他能听到其他人微弱的呼喊声。但当他到达他们跳下的船尾时，水里已经看不到任何人了。漆黑的夜晚让哈维的救援任务变得更加困难，他努力在雨、风和拍打在他脸上的海浪中看清周围的环境。哈维大声呼喊其他人，直到嗓子沙哑。没有任何回应。“蓝铃号”静静地沉入大海，熄灭了火焰。当哈维最终发现
body of Renée Duparalt, he tried to resuscitate her, but she was already deceased. Harvey tied her to the life raft so her remains would be safe. The strenuous actions of launching the dinghy by himself rowing it solo and searching for survivors had left him exhausted. As the sun rose the next morning, he ate the emergency rations in the dinghy. The sun helped warm up the freezing Captain Harvey, though waves continued to drench him repeatedly. By early afternoon, he spotted the Gulf Lion oil tanker and was able to signal for rescue. Lieutenant Murdoch asked Captain Harvey why he hadn't tried to use the Bluebells radio to call for help. Harvey said he knew it wouldn't work as the main mast had taken out the antenna when it
蕾妮·杜佩罗的尸体时，他试图对她进行心肺复苏，但她已经死亡。哈维把她系在救生筏上，这样她的遗体就会安全。独自放下小艇、独自划船和搜寻幸存者的艰苦行动让他精疲力竭。第二天早晨太阳升起时，他吃了小艇里的应急口粮。阳光帮助温暖了冻僵的哈维船长，尽管海浪不断地反复浸透他。下午早些时候，他发现了“海湾狮号”油轮，并成功发出求救信号。默多克中尉问哈维船长为什么不尝试使用“蓝铃号”的无线电呼救。哈维说他知道那没用，因为主桅杆倒下时
fell. Despite having flares in the emergency kit in the dinghy, it hadn't even occurred to him to use them. Plus, he explained, they were buried deep in the kit, making them hard to reach. Finally, Lieutenant Murdoch concluded his questioning of Captain Julian Harvey and turned his attention to the Blue Bell's owner, Harold Pegg. Lieutenant Murdoch told Harvey he could stay to listen to his employer's testimony and would be allowed to ask questions if he disagreed with anything Harold Pegg said. A few moments later, the door to the hearing room burst
摧毁了天线。尽管小艇的应急包里有信号弹，但他甚至没想过要使用它们。此外，他解释说，它们被埋在应急包深处，很难拿到。最后，默多克中尉结束了对朱利安·哈维船长的询问，将注意力转向了“蓝铃号”的所有者哈罗德·佩格。默多克中尉告诉哈维，他可以留下来听他雇主的证词，如果他不同意哈罗德·佩格所说的任何内容，他将被允许提问。片刻之后，听证室的门被撞开了。
open. Coast Guard Captain Robert Barber, who was handling the investigation alongside Lieutenant Murdoch, rushed in. He had urgent news. Another survivor had been found. On the morning of Thursday November 16, Second Officer Nicolaus Spakidakis stared out at the water as his ship passed through the Northwest Providence Channel. The Captain Theo was a Greek freighter that was on its way to Houston, Texas, and Nicolaus was acting as watcher. Standing high up on the bridge, he spotted a few other ships in the distance. The sun was shining brightly, making Nicolaus' job easier. Thousands of whitecaps dotted the surface of the water, but while most ebbed and flowed with the waves, one did not. The tiny white object caught Nicolaus's eye. He stared at the object,
海岸警卫队罗伯特·巴伯（Robert Barber）上尉，他与默多克中尉一起负责调查，冲了进来。他带来了紧急消息。又发现了一名幸存者。11月16日星期四上午，二副尼古拉斯·斯帕基达基斯（Nicolaus Spakidakis）盯着水面，看着他的船穿过西北普罗维登斯海峡。“西奥船长号”（Captain Theo）是一艘正在前往德克萨斯州休斯顿的希腊货轮，尼古拉斯担任瞭望员。站在高高的舰桥上，他发现远处还有几艘船。阳光明媚，让尼古拉斯的工作变得轻松。成千上万的白浪点缀着水面，但大多数随着海浪起伏，有一个却不是。那个微小的白色物体引起了尼古拉斯的注意。他盯着那个物体，
squinting to get a better look. Nicolaus suspected it was a piece of debris, and then he spotted the outline of a person inside. Initially, Nikolaus wondered if he was seeing a fisherman on a dinghy before realising they were out way too far for that. Nikolaus called over the ship's captain. By now, the object was about a mile away from the starboard bow of the freighter. The ship slowly drew closer, and as it did so, Nikolaus and the captain realised they were looking at a tiny, rectangular-shaped life raft. It was two and a half feet by five feet and made of canvas-covered cork with rope webbing in the middle. The person inside was a female child. She was sitting up but
眯起眼睛仔细看。尼古拉斯怀疑那是一块残骸，然后他看到了里面有一个人的轮廓。起初，尼古拉斯怀疑自己是否在小艇上看到了渔民，但随后意识到他们离岸太远了，不可能有渔民。尼古拉斯叫来了船长。此时，该物体距离货轮右舷约一英里。船慢慢靠近，当靠近时，尼古拉斯和船长意识到他们看到的是一个微小的长方形救生筏。它长2.5英尺，宽5英尺，由帆布覆盖的软木制成，中间有绳网。里面的人是一个女童。她坐着，但
reclining slightly in a stiff, uncomfortable pose, her legs hanging over the life raft into the water. Her hair was bleached blonde by the sun and she wore a white blouse and pink pedal pushers. wore a white blouse and pink pedal pushers. The girl waved weakly at the ship's crew, who were staring at her in shock. The captain ordered his crew to stop the engines. Because the ship's lifeboats were large, he worried that lowering one down to the girl would knock her off the raft and into the water. So a makeshift raft was created from empty oil drums. The captain suddenly noticed something alarming. The fins of several sharks were circling the girl's raft and she was still sitting with her legs dangling in the water. He called for his crew to hurry up and the oil drums were lowered over the side.
姿势僵硬且不舒服地微微后仰，双腿悬在救生筏外浸在水里。她的头发被太阳晒成了漂白色，穿着一件白色衬衫和粉色踏板裤。女孩向船上的船员们虚弱地挥手，他们正震惊地盯着她。船长命令船员停止引擎。因为船上的救生艇很大，他担心放下救生艇会把她从筏子上撞进水里。于是，他们用空油桶制作了一个简易筏子。船长突然注意到一件令人担忧的事情。几条鲨鱼的鳍正在女孩的筏子周围盘旋，而她仍然坐着，双腿悬在水里。他大声催促船员快点，油桶被放到了船边。
A crew member followed and picked up the little girl. As soon as she was in his arms, she fell limp before being hoisted up to the ship's deck. It was clear she had been alone at sea for some time. Her face was gaunt and sunburnt, her lips were swollen, and her eyes dazed and unfocused. She was severely dehydrated and obviously in shock. Crew members carried the girl to a spare cabin and placed her on a bunk before bringing her water, orange juice, and damp towels. The captain asked the girl her name, explaining he would alert the coast guard so they could notify her family.
一名船员跟了下去，抱起了小女孩。她一被抱进怀里，就瘫软了下来，随后被吊上了船甲板。很明显，她在海上独自漂流了一段时间。她的脸消瘦且被晒伤，嘴唇肿胀，眼神呆滞且无法聚焦。她严重脱水，显然处于休克状态。船员们把女孩抱到一个空余的船舱，把她放在铺位上，然后给她拿来了水、橙汁和湿毛巾。船长问女孩的名字，解释说他会通知海岸警卫队，以便他们通知她的家人。
Wordlessly, the girl shook her head and pointed down with her thumb. The captain interpreted this as the girl saying her family had been lost in the same accident as her. He tried to reassure her, stating, you can't be sure they are lost, maybe some other ship saved them. The girl shook her head again and pointed at the water. Then she said in a hoarse voice, bluebell, before telling the captain her name. Terry Jo Dupereault. The captain notified the Coast Guard of 11-year-old Terry Jo's rescue. A helicopter was sent to collect the girl, and as she was lifted into a basket, she weakly waved goodbye to the Captain Theo's crew. Terry Jo was transferred to a hospital in Miami where she was treated for shock and exposure.
女孩一言不发地摇了摇头，用拇指指了指下方。船长将其解读为女孩在说她的家人在和她同一场事故中遇难了。他试图安慰她，说：“你不能确定他们失踪了，也许其他船只救了他们。”女孩再次摇了摇头，指了指水面。然后她用沙哑的声音说：“蓝铃号”，接着告诉了船长她的名字：特里·乔·杜佩罗。船长将11岁的特里·乔获救的消息通知了海岸警卫队。一架直升机被派来接走女孩，当她被吊进篮子时，她虚弱地向“西奥船长号”的船员挥手告别。特里·乔被送往迈阿密的一家医院，在那里她接受了休克和暴露治疗。
Exhausted from her 84-hour long ordeal, Terry Jo slept for days. By Sunday November 19, after several days treatment and rest, she began to appear well again. Her room was kept under close guard and her aunt and uncle flew from Green Bay, Wisconsin to be with her. On Monday November 20, Terry Jo shared her story with the Coast Guard from her hospital bed. Everything had been going well on her family's vacation up until the night of Sunday November 12. That evening, Mary Harvey made everyone chicken cacciatore and salad, which they ate together. At around 9pm, Terry Jo had gone down to the small cabin she shared
特里·乔在经历了84小时的磨难后精疲力竭，睡了好几天。到11月19日星期日，经过几天的治疗和休息，她看起来又好转了。她的房间受到严密看守，她的姑姑和姑父从威斯康星州绿湾飞来陪伴她。11月20日星期一，特里·乔在病床上向海岸警卫队讲述了她的故事。在11月12日星期日晚上之前，她家人的假期一切都很顺利。那天晚上，玛丽·哈维做了鸡肉猎人风味（chicken cacciatore）和沙拉，大家一起吃了晚餐。晚上9点左右，特里·乔回到她和
with her little sister Renee and went to sleep. Everyone else had stayed up. Terry Jo slept deeply until she was suddenly woken by the sound of her brother Brian screaming, help daddy, help. At the same time, Terry Jo heard the sound of footsteps running and stomping. Then all fell silent, except for a few creaks that were normal for the boat at night. Terry Joe lay still in bed, shaking and terrified. She waited between five and ten minutes, then got up and slowly crept out to the main cabin. Lying on the floor of the main cabin were the bodies of her mother and brother, both in a pool of blood. Terry Jo knew they were dead. In shock, she somehow kept moving and walked up the stairs towards the deck. She could see
小妹妹蕾妮共用的小舱室睡觉去了。其他人都没有睡。特里·乔睡得很沉，直到突然被她哥哥布莱恩的尖叫声惊醒：“救命，爸爸，救命。”与此同时，特里·乔听到了奔跑和跺脚的脚步声。然后一切都归于寂静，除了几声船只在夜间正常的吱呀声。特里·乔躺在床上，一动不动，浑身发抖，惊恐万分。她等了五到十分钟，然后起床，慢慢爬向主舱。主舱地板上躺着她母亲和哥哥的尸体，两人都浸在血泊中。特里·乔知道他们死了。在震惊中，她不知何故继续移动，走上楼梯朝甲板走去。她可以看到
more puddles of blood on the starboard side of the cockpit as well as what looked like a knife. All of a sudden, Captain Julian Harvey appeared and ran towards her. Terry Jo started to ask what's happening when Harvey grabbed her and roughly shoved her back down the stairs saying, get back down there. Scared and her heart racing, Terry Jo did as she was told, returning to her bunk and huddling in a corner. Soon she heard the sloshing sound of water, followed a few minutes later by water that reeked of oil starting to flood her cabin. starting to flood her cabin. Then Captain Harvey reappeared in the doorway. She couldn't see his face due to the shadows of the dark room. He was holding something in his hands which might have been her brother's rifle, but Terry-Joe struggled to see. Harvey stood staring at her for a long time. Terry Joe sat frozen with fear. Finally, Harvey turned
驾驶舱右舷有更多的血迹，还有一把看起来像刀的东西。突然，朱利安·哈维船长出现并向她跑来。特里·乔开始问发生了什么事，哈维抓住她，粗暴地把她推回楼梯下，说：“滚回去。”特里·乔吓坏了，心跳加速，她照做了，回到铺位，蜷缩在角落里。很快，她听到了水流声，几分钟后，散发着油味的水开始涌入她的船舱。开始涌入她的船舱。然后哈维船长再次出现在门口。由于黑暗房间的阴影，她看不清他的脸。他手里拿着什么东西，可能是她哥哥的步枪，但特里·乔看不清楚。哈维站在那里盯着她看了很久。特里·乔吓得僵住了。最后，哈维转过身
around and left. Some pounding noises followed and water continued to seep into the cabin, reaching Terry Joe's mattress. Terry Joe knew she had to get out. The water was up to her waist as she stood and made her way back up the stairs again. When she reached the cockpit, she saw that the boat's dinghy and black rubber life raft had been launched over the side. Is the ship sinking? she cried out. Yes, Harvey answered. He was standing behind her near the front of the boat. Then he handed her the line to the dinghy and told her to hold it. Terry-Joe took the line and Harvey continued rushing forwards to get something. As he did so, the line slipped from Terry- Joe's fingers. When he returned mere seconds later,
离开了。随后传来了一些撞击声，水继续渗入船舱，没过了特里·乔的床垫。特里·乔知道她必须离开。当她站起来再次爬上楼梯时，水已经没到了她的腰部。当她到达驾驶舱时，她看到船上的小艇和黑色橡胶救生筏已经被放下去了。“船要沉了吗？”她大喊道。 “是的，”哈维回答。他站在她身后，靠近船头。然后他把小艇的缆绳递给她，让她抓住。特里·乔抓住了缆绳，哈维继续匆忙向前去拿东西。就在这时，缆绳从特里·乔的手指间滑落。几秒钟后他回来时，
he shouted, the dinghy's gone. He then leapt overboard towards the dinghy, which was floating away from the blue bowl. Left all alone, Terry Joe somehow remembered the white cork life float which was kept attached to the top of the main cabin. She retrieved the float by untying the knot that held it in place as the deck beneath her feet slid underwater. Then, Terry Jo pushed the lifeboat in front of her while half swimming and half crawling across the main sail, launching the float in the water. The float was so small that Terry Jo couldn't lie down on it. She tried to stay hunched down low, aware that Captain Harvey was out there somewhere in the dark. She had no food,
他喊道：“小艇不见了。”然后他跳入水中，朝正在远离“蓝铃号”的小艇游去。只剩下特里·乔一个人，她不知何故想起了系在主舱顶部的白色软木救生浮具。当她脚下的甲板滑入水下时，她解开了固定浮具的结，取下了它。然后，特里·乔一边游泳一边爬行，推着救生浮具穿过主帆，将其推入水中。浮具太小了，特里·乔无法躺在上面。她试图保持蜷缩姿势，意识到哈维船长就在黑暗中的某个地方。她没有食物、
water or warm clothing and nothing that would allow her to signal for help. Terry Jo drifted through the water all night, cold and unable to see. The wind was howling, and waves periodically washed over her. When the sun rose the following morning, it helped warm her up, but it soon burnt her skin and made her dehydration worse. The cork float she sat on wasn't intended to be kept in the water for long periods of time and its material beneath her began to disintegrate. This led to parrotfish biting Terry Jo's exposed legs and feet. Monday November 13 slowly passed with no help arriving.
水或保暖衣物，也没有任何可以让她发出求救信号的东西。特里·乔整晚都在水里漂流，寒冷且看不见东西。风在呼啸，海浪不时拍打在她身上。第二天早晨太阳升起时，它帮助她温暖了身体，但很快又灼伤了她的皮肤，加重了她的脱水。她坐的软木浮具并不打算在水中长时间浸泡，她下方的材料开始分解。这导致鹦嘴鱼咬伤了特里·乔暴露的双腿和脚。11月13日星期一在没有救援的情况下缓慢过去。
Terry Jo saw a ship in the distance but it was too far away to see her. The following day was cloudy and cooler. A few aeroplanes flew by, including a small red one that was quite close to her. It was one of two rescue planes searching for the Bluebells passengers. The red plane flew in a grid pattern above Terry Jo and circled her. She waved at it frantically, but again went unnoticed. At one point that afternoon, a pot of Pilar whales surfaced about 30 yards from Terry Jo's float and swam alongside her for a time. She found comfort in their presence. Her sleep that night was plagued by strange hallucinations and dreams. At one point she saw her father sitting and drinking a glass of red wine. He called out to her,
特里·乔在远处看到了一艘船，但距离太远，看不见她。第二天多云且凉爽。几架飞机飞过，包括一架离她很近的小红飞机。那是搜寻“蓝铃号”乘客的两架救援飞机之一。红色的飞机在特里·乔上方以网格模式飞行并盘旋。她疯狂地向它挥手，但再次被忽视。那天下午，一群领航鲸在距离特里·乔的浮具约30码处浮出水面，并与她游了一段距离。她从它们的存在中找到了安慰。那天晚上，她的睡眠被奇怪的幻觉和梦境所困扰。有一次，她看到父亲坐着喝一杯红酒。他向她喊道：
Come on, Terry Jo, we're leaving now. By her third day at sea, Terry Jo was well and truly suffering from heat exhaustion and dehydration. All of her muscles ached and her lips were rough and swollen. As more of the cork float had broken and disintegrated through the middle, she was restricted to sitting on the edges. This meant she had to remain upright at all times. Terry Jo began to hallucinate more frequently and became oblivious to the waves and sea around her. Terry Jo eventually found a way to remain on the float safely and more comfortably. She rested her shoulders on one edge, her arms on either side,
“来吧，特里·乔，我们要走了。”到海上第三天，特里·乔确实患上了热衰竭和脱水。她所有的肌肉都酸痛，嘴唇粗糙肿胀。由于软木浮具中间部分已经破裂分解，她只能坐在边缘。这意味着她必须始终保持直立。特里·乔开始更频繁地产生幻觉，对周围的海浪和海洋变得麻木。特里·乔最终找到了一种安全且更舒适地待在浮具上的方法。她把肩膀靠在一边，双臂放在两侧，
and her thighs on the other edge with her legs in the water. By the fourth day, Terry Jo was in a near-comatose state. Her blood pressure had dipped and her temperature soared to 105 degrees Fahrenheit, or 40.5 degrees Celsius. Terry Jo was barely conscious, but at around mid-morning she suddenly opened her eyes to see the Greek freighter, Captain Theo, looming before her. Terry-Jo found the strength to force herself upright and wave at the ship, then paddle towards it. She was finally rescued. Terry-Jo's version of events differed notably from Julian Harvey's. After Coast Guard Captain Robert Barber heard her describe what had happened the night that
大腿放在另一边，双腿浸在水里。到第四天，特里·乔处于近乎昏迷的状态。她的血压下降，体温飙升至105华氏度，即40.5摄氏度。特里·乔几乎失去了知觉，但在上午中旬左右，她突然睁开眼睛，看到希腊货轮“西奥船长号”出现在她面前。特里·乔找到了力量，强迫自己坐直并向船挥手，然后向它划去。她终于获救了。特里·乔对事件的描述与朱利安·哈维的描述有显著不同。在海岸警卫队罗伯特·巴伯上尉听完她描述那天晚上发生的事情后……
the bluebell sank, he asked the 11-year-old whether she had ever seen a fire at any time on the boat. Terry Jo said she hadn't, nor did she see or smell smoke. The Coast Guard investigators were now certain that Julian Harvey had been lying. The bluebell hadn't gone down due to an accident. In fact, Terry Jo's descriptions of her mother and brother's bodies along with the blood she'd seen near the cockpit made investigators certain that the boat had been deliberately sunk to cover murder. When Captain Harvey received word of Terry Jo's survival during the Coast Guard hearing, he'd appeared shocked and unsettled. After initially expressing his
蓝铃号沉没后，他问这位11岁的女孩，在船上是否曾看到过火灾。特丽·乔说她没有，也没有看到或闻到烟味。海岸警卫队的调查人员现在确信朱利安·哈维一直在撒谎。蓝铃号并非因事故沉没。事实上，特丽·乔对她母亲和兄弟尸体的描述，加上她在驾驶舱附近看到的血迹，让调查人员确信这艘船是被人蓄意凿沉以掩盖谋杀罪行。当哈维船长在海岸警卫队的听证会上得知特丽·乔幸存的消息时，他显得既震惊又不安。在最初表达了他的
amazement and stating, isn't that wonderful, he then abruptly stood and walked to a nearby window. After staring outside at the ground below for about a minute, he turned and headed towards the door. His employer and the Blue Bell's owner, Harold Pegg, were still giving his testimony. Upon seeing that Harvey appeared to be leaving, Coast Guard Lieutenant Ernest Murdoch asked him, "'Don't you want to remain for the rest of the testimony? You have that privilege.' Harvey smiled and shook his head, then left.
惊讶并说“那不是太好了吗”之后，他突然站起来，走到附近的一扇窗前。盯着外面的地面看了大约一分钟后，他转身朝门口走去。他的雇主兼蓝铃号的船主哈罗德·佩格当时还在作证。看到哈维似乎要离开，海岸警卫队中尉欧内斯特·默多克问他：“你不想留下来听完剩下的证词吗？你有这个特权。”哈维笑了笑，摇了摇头，然后离开了。
Lieutenant Murdoch and his partner, Captain Barber, were suspicious about Harvey's abrupt departure right after he'd found out Terry-Joe survived. They paused the proceedings to quickly call the Miami Police Department and request that Terry-Joe Duparol's hospital room be kept guard. Casefile will be back shortly. Thank you for supporting us by listening to this episode's sponsors. Thank you for listening to this episode's ads. By supporting our sponsors, you support Casefile to continue to deliver quality content. Before his career as a skipper, Julian Harvey had been an Air Force pilot, serving in World War II and the Korean War. His service saw him receive a number of
默多克中尉和他的搭档巴伯船长对哈维在得知特丽·乔幸存后立即离开的行为感到怀疑。他们暂停了听证会，迅速致电迈阿密警察局，要求对特丽·乔·杜佩罗的病房进行看守。Casefile稍后回来。感谢您通过收听本期节目的赞助商来支持我们。感谢您收听本期节目的广告。通过支持我们的赞助商，您支持Casefile继续提供高质量的内容。在成为船长之前，朱利安·哈维曾是一名空军飞行员，参加过第二次世界大战和朝鲜战争。他的服役经历让他获得了许多
medals. But his first love had always been sailing. As a teenager growing up in New York, he had built sailboats and took them out on the Long Island Sound. After he retired from his military career in 1958, he moved to Florida to pursue a full-time career as a master of a yacht. People in Fort Lauderdale regarded him as a handsome and dashing war hero. In July 1961, Julian Harvey married aspiring writer Mary Jordan, who was 10 years his junior. Jordan who was 10 years his junior. Mary wasn't Harvey's first wife. He had been married five times before and was known to be unfaithful to his spouses. Some of his marriages ended with Harvey telling his wives he no longer loved them, but more than one ended in tragedy. In 1949, when Harvey was 32, he was driving along a rainy highway with his second wife, Joan Boylan, and her mother Myrtle when his car skidded into a bridge railing, then sunk into a
勋章。但他最初的挚爱一直是航海。作为在纽约长大的少年，他曾建造帆船，并驾驶它们在长岛海湾航行。1958年从军旅生涯退役后，他搬到佛罗里达，追求成为游艇船长的全职职业。劳德代尔堡的人们视他为一位英俊潇洒的战争英雄。1961年7月，朱利安·哈维娶了立志成为作家的玛丽·乔丹，她比他小10岁。玛丽并不是哈维的第一任妻子。他之前结过五次婚，并以对配偶不忠而闻名。他的一些婚姻以哈维告诉妻子他不再爱她们而告终，但其中不止一段婚姻以悲剧收场。1949年，32岁的哈维正开车载着第二任妻子琼·博伊兰和她的母亲默特尔行驶在雨中的公路上，车子滑向桥栏杆，随后沉入了一片
bayou. Joan and Myrtle both drowned, trapped in the car. Harvey walked away unharmed. He attributed this to the fact he'd seen the accident coming at the last second, prompting him to open his door and jump out before the collision. He made no attempt to save his wife or mother-in-law. Bypassers who came across the accident saw him standing on the bridge calmly, watching others diving into the water. A highway patrol officer and the police diver who responded to the incident were suspicious, especially when the car was found with all four doors closed and the driver's side window wound down. But there was no hard evidence indicating a crime and Harvey was permitted to move on with his life. He received a payout from a life insurance policy he'd taken out on Joan,
河口。琼和默特尔都被困在车里溺亡了。哈维毫发无损地走了出来。他将此归因于他在最后一刻预见到了事故，促使他在碰撞前打开车门跳了出去。他没有试图营救他的妻子或岳母。路过的行人看到他平静地站在桥上，看着别人潜入水中。负责处理此事的公路巡警和警察潜水员对此表示怀疑，尤其是当发现车子的四扇车门都是关闭的，且驾驶座一侧的车窗是摇下的。但没有确凿证据表明这是一起犯罪，哈维被允许继续他的生活。他从为琼购买的人寿保险单中获得了一笔赔付，
and within weeks of her death, he was living with another woman. In 1954, Harvey and his fifth wife purchased a 68-foot yacht called the Torbatross. wife purchased a 68-foot yacht called the Torbatros. Within a year of buying it, Harvey and several friends took it out one day and rammed it into a submerged battleship. The Torbatros sank, but all on board survived, with Harvey suing the US government due to the submerged wreck causing the accident. Coast Guard investigator Robert Barber, who was assigned this case six years before the Bluebell sank, believed Harvey had deliberately run into the wreck. It was a well-known navigational hazard that was clearly marked with a buoy and its exact location was clearly visible. Furthermore, a passenger who'd been on the yacht said Harvey had circled the
在她去世后的几周内，他就与另一名女性同居了。1954年，哈维和他的第五任妻子购买了一艘68英尺长的游艇，名为“托巴托斯号”。买下它不到一年，哈维和几位朋友有一天驾驶它出海，撞上了一艘沉没的战列舰。“托巴托斯号”沉没了，但船上所有人都幸存了下来，哈维还因沉船残骸导致事故而起诉了美国政府。在蓝铃号沉没六年前负责此案的海岸警卫队调查员罗伯特·巴伯认为，哈维是蓄意撞向残骸的。那是一个众所周知的航行危险点，有浮标清晰标记，其确切位置清晰可见。此外，一名曾在游艇上的乘客说，哈维在碰撞前曾绕着
wreck twice before the collision. Ultimately, the court found differently and awarded Harvey a $14,258 payout. Using the proceeds of this settlement, Harvey bought another boat, an 81-foot yacht called Valiant. In 1958, the Valiant was spotted on fire in the marina where it was kept. A passerby was able to douse the flames and the boat was saved. A few months later, Harvey sailed the Valiant to Cuba. Harvey sailed the Valiant to Cuba. When he was 10 miles off the north coast of Cuba, the yacht caught fire. Harvey and his sole crewmen were able to escape as the Valiant burnt and sank. A passing boat picked up Harvey and he was able to collect a $40,000 insurance payout for losing his second boat. Some were suspicious due to the earlier fire on the Valiant, and a friend of Harvey's later told author Richard Logan that Harvey had
残骸转了两圈。最终，法院做出了不同的裁决，判给哈维14,258美元的赔偿金。利用这笔和解金，哈维买了另一艘船，一艘81英尺长的游艇，名为“英勇号”。1958年，“英勇号”在停泊的码头被发现起火。一名路人成功扑灭了火焰，船只得以保全。几个月后，哈维驾驶“英勇号”前往古巴。当他航行到古巴北海岸10英里外时，游艇起火了。哈维和他的唯一船员在“英勇号”燃烧沉没时成功逃生。一艘路过的船只救起了哈维，他因损失第二艘船而获得了4万美元的保险赔付。由于“英勇号”之前发生过火灾，一些人对此表示怀疑，哈维的一位朋友后来告诉作家理查德·洛根，哈维曾
told him he'd burned and sank the yacht because he needed the money. In the fall of 1960, Julian Harvey met a flight attendant and aspiring writer named Mary Jordan while he was skippering a yacht that had been chartered for a party. Mary and Harvey hit it off and were married in Mexico in July 1961. The pair soon began arguing frequently, often about money. Mary's father was unwell, so she promised to send her family $25 per month to help pay for his hospital care. Harvey was unhappy about this. Two months after their wedding, he took out a $20,000 life insurance policy on his new wife. The policy included a double indemnity clause
告诉他，他烧毁并凿沉了那艘游艇，因为他需要钱。1960年秋，朱利安·哈维在担任一艘派对包租游艇的船长时，结识了一位空姐兼立志成为作家的玛丽·乔丹。玛丽和哈维一见钟情，并于1961年7月在墨西哥结婚。两人很快开始频繁争吵，通常是因为钱。玛丽的父亲身体不好，所以她承诺每月寄给家人25美元，以帮助支付他的住院费用。哈维对此很不高兴。婚后两个月，他为新婚妻子购买了一份2万美元的人寿保险。该保单包含一项双倍赔付条款，
that meant if she died in an accident and her body wasn't recovered, he would receive $40,000. One month before the Duparolt family arrived in Florida, the Blue Bells owner Harold Pegg hired Julian Harvey as a skipper. Harvey would receive $300 per month as well as free accommodation on the catch in exchange for taking tourists out on chartered cruises. The Dupar Alts had been the first clients that Harvey had taken out. After Terry Jo was rescued, her description of what had happened on Sunday November 12 pointed to a violent attack caused by a person, not a weather event. And a number of people had noticed holes and inconsistencies in
意味着如果她死于事故且尸体未被找回，他将获得4万美元。在杜佩罗一家抵达佛罗里达前一个月，蓝铃号的船主哈罗德·佩格聘请了朱利安·哈维担任船长。哈维每月将获得300美元的报酬，以及在双桅帆船上的免费住宿，以换取带游客进行包租巡游。杜佩罗一家是哈维接待的第一批客户。特丽·乔获救后，她对11月12日星期日所发生事情的描述，指向了一场由人为而非天气事件引发的暴力袭击。而且从一开始，就有不少人注意到了
Harvey's story from the start. While most of the crew from the Gulf Lion who'd rescued Harvey empathised with him, others were suspicious of him. Some found his demeanor rot, noting that he was joking and laughing despite his ordeal and the presence of seven-year-old Rene Duparolt's body. They heard Harvey tell their captain that he didn't know what happened to his wife. Then later he amended his story when talking to the crew, saying he had seen Mary jump overboard. Harvey had also initially told the Gulf Lions crew that Arthur and Jean Dupereault had been killed instantly when they were struck by the falling mast. Yet, at the hearing several days later, he said only that some passengers had been injured. The Coast Guard
哈维故事中的漏洞和矛盾之处。虽然救起哈维的“海湾狮号”船员大多对他表示同情，但其他人却对他心存怀疑。有些人觉得他的举止很奇怪，注意到尽管经历了磨难，且现场还有7岁雷内·杜佩罗的尸体，他却在开玩笑和欢笑。他们听到哈维告诉他们的船长，他不知道妻子发生了什么事。后来在与船员交谈时，他修改了说法，称他看到玛丽跳船了。哈维最初还告诉“海湾狮号”的船员，亚瑟和琼·杜佩罗在桅杆倒塌时被击中，当场死亡。然而，几天后的听证会上，他只说有几名乘客受伤。海岸警卫队
investigators noted some contradictions too. They found Harvey's story of a fire unlikely. There was a lighthouse stationed just a few miles from where the Bluebell sank, yet the lookout there hadn't seen any flames. And Harvey's description of how the broken mast plunged directly down into the boat's deck wasn't consistent with what they'd seen in similar circumstances. If a mast was broken by heavy wind, it tended to fall sideways and overboard. Then there was the fact that Harvey hadn't used the flares in the dinghy's emergency kit to signal for help, supposedly because he either forgot about them or couldn't be bothered rummaging through the back. Following extensive interviews and investigations, the Coast Guard
调查人员也注意到了其中的一些矛盾。他们发现哈维关于火灾的说法不太可能。在蓝铃号沉没地点几英里外就有一个灯塔，但那里的瞭望员并没有看到任何火焰。而且哈维关于断裂的桅杆直接坠入船甲板的描述，与他们在类似情况下所见的情况不符。如果桅杆是被大风吹断的，它通常会向侧面倾倒并落入海中。此外，哈维并没有使用救生艇应急包里的信号弹来求救，据称是因为他要么忘了，要么懒得去翻找。经过广泛的访谈和调查，海岸警卫队
officers in charge of the Bluebell case put together a theory. They suspected that Julian Harvey had intended to kill his wife Mary while out at sea and dispose of her body overboard, with the aim of collecting the life insurance payout. Harold Pegg had noticed scratches on Harvey's arm after he was rescued. Harvey said they were from scrambling through the rigging after the yacht's mast broke. But Harold was adamant that the scratches were clearly made by fingernails, and Mary had had long nails. Investigators thought Harvey had probably stabbed Mary in their shared cabin and she fought back. His plan was likely to later throw her body overboard when everyone else was asleep and discover her missing the following morning.
负责蓝铃号案件的警官们整理出了一套理论。他们怀疑朱利安·哈维打算在海上杀害他的妻子玛丽，并将她的尸体抛入海中，目的是骗取人寿保险赔付。哈罗德·佩格在哈维获救后注意到了他手臂上的抓痕。哈维说那是桅杆断裂后他在索具中挣扎时留下的。但哈罗德坚称这些抓痕显然是指甲抓出来的，而玛丽留着长指甲。调查人员认为，哈维很可能在他们共用的船舱里刺伤了玛丽，而她进行了反抗。他的计划很可能是等大家都睡着后将她的尸体抛入海中，并在第二天早上发现她失踪。
The Coast Guard investigators believed that Harvey hadn't intended for the Duperrault family to die or the Bluebell to sink. But perhaps Arthur Duperrault had come across Harvey while he was either murdering Mary or disposing of her body. To cover up his crime, Harvey killed Arthur and then Jean Duperrault who might have also been a witness. The noise woke Brian Duperrault who cried out for his father. Harvey killed him too. Terry Jo had spotted the bodies of her mother and brother lying dead on the floor but hadn't seen anyone else. Because she had been sleeping downstairs, Terry Jo was initially left to drown as Harvey scrambled to sink the catch so that the mass murder would instead look like a terrible accident.
海岸警卫队的调查人员认为，哈维并不打算让杜佩罗一家死亡或让蓝铃号沉没。但也许亚瑟·杜佩罗在哈维谋杀玛丽或处理尸体时撞见了这一切。为了掩盖罪行，哈维杀害了亚瑟，随后又杀害了可能也是目击者的琼·杜佩罗。声音吵醒了布莱恩·杜佩罗，他哭着喊父亲。哈维也杀了他。特丽·乔发现了她母亲和兄弟倒在地上的尸体，但没有看到其他人。因为她当时睡在楼下，哈维在忙着凿沉帆船以使这场大规模谋杀看起来像是一场可怕的事故时，最初没管她，让她自生自灭。
When she went upstairs and interrupted Harvey, it appeared he had considered killing her, too. He subsequently appeared in her doorway, apparently carrying her brother's rifle. Ultimately, he hadn't shot her, as he'd decided she would drown anyway with the catch sinking. An autopsy indicated Renee Dupereault had drowned but couldn't determine if this had been done intentionally by another person or was the result of the bluebell sinking. Investigators suspected her mother Jean might have tried to shield her during the attack, and in the process of Jean's murder, Renee was struck or hit her head, falling unconscious.
当她上楼并打断哈维时，他似乎也考虑过杀掉她。他随后出现在她的门口，手里似乎拿着她兄弟的步枪。最终，他没有开枪，因为他认定她反正会随着帆船沉没而溺水。尸检显示雷内·杜佩罗溺水身亡，但无法确定这是他人蓄意为之，还是蓝铃号沉没的结果。调查人员怀疑她的母亲琼在袭击过程中可能试图保护她，而在谋杀琼的过程中，雷内被击中或头部受撞击，陷入昏迷。
She subsequently drowned when the blue bell went under, and Harvey retrieved her floating body to bolster his story. Investigators believed that Harvey hadn't used the emergency kit flares to signal for help because he didn't want to be found too close to the site where the Bluebell sank. If the wreckage was recovered, evidence on board might have disproved his claims about what happened. The Bluebell was never found, and nor were the bodies of the four other victims. Captain Harvey's demeanour throughout the Coast Guard hearing had been interesting. He was obviously nervous and stammered often. He became even more uncomfortable after it was
她随后在蓝铃号沉没时溺水身亡，哈维找回了她漂浮的尸体以支撑他的故事。调查人员认为，哈维没有使用应急包里的信号弹求救，是因为他不想被发现离蓝铃号沉没地点太近。如果残骸被找回，船上的证据可能会推翻他关于所发生之事的说法。蓝铃号从未被找到，其他四名受害者的尸体也未被找到。哈维船长在整个海岸警卫队听证会上的表现很有意思。他显然很紧张，经常结巴。在得知
announced that Terry Joe Dupereault had been found alive, abruptly leaving the hearing without explanation. Just before noon on Friday November 17, the day after Harvey left the hearing, a cleaner at Miami's Sandman Motel knocked on the door of room 17. A man named John Munro had booked the room for one night the previous day. It was just before checkout time and she needed to make up the room. When there was no response from inside, the cleaner unlocked the door and let herself in. She was met by a blast of cool air from the air conditioner which had been left on. The breeze was pleasant due to the stifling Miami heat outside.
特丽·乔·杜佩罗被发现还活着的消息后，他变得更加不安，并毫无解释地突然离开了听证会。11月17日星期五中午前，也就是哈维离开听证会的第二天，迈阿密沙人汽车旅馆的一名清洁工敲响了17号房间的门。一个名叫约翰·门罗的男子前一天预订了该房间一晚。当时离退房时间不远了，她需要打扫房间。里面没有回应，清洁工打开门走了进去。她迎面感受到空调吹出的一阵凉风，空调一直开着。由于迈阿密室外闷热，这阵微风让人感到舒适。
But the cleaner also noticed a slightly strange smell. She thought little of it and set about doing her job. The room had two twin beds and the cleaner began to strip the sheets from one. When she pulled back the covers, she noticed one of the sheets had a small patch of blood on it. She then went to the bathroom to gather the towels. The door was closed and when she tried to open it, the handle moved but the door wouldn't open. The cleaner could tell there was something pushed up against its other side. It felt like something large and soft. She noticed that the strange odour she'd smelt was also stronger in this part of the room. Suddenly realising that what she could smell was blood, she began to scream. The hotel manager was summoned by the commotion and he too tried to open the bathroom door.
但清洁工也注意到了一种略显奇怪的气味。她没多想，就开始做她的工作。房间里有两张单人床，清洁工开始拆掉其中一张床的床单。当她掀开被子时，她注意到其中一张床单上有一小块血迹。然后她去浴室收集毛巾。门是关着的，当她试图打开时，把手动了，但门打不开。清洁工能感觉到有什么东西顶在门的另一侧。感觉像是一个又大又软的东西。她注意到她闻到的那种奇怪气味在房间的这一部分更浓了。突然意识到她闻到的是血腥味，她开始尖叫。旅馆经理被骚动声叫来，他也试图打开浴室的门。
When he couldn't push it open, he called the police. A patrol officer arrived at the scene at 12.14pm and was able to force the door partially open by using his shoulder. Sticking his head in the open space, he saw the body of a man lying on the floor, covered in blood. The officer had previously worked at the Miami Harbour and recognised the man as Blue Bell captain Julian Harvey. Investigators were able to piece together Harvey's movements after leaving Coast Guard headquarters the day prior. He had retrieved a suitcase from his car which was parked nearby, then caught a cab to the
当他推不开门时，他报了警。一名巡警在中午12点14分到达现场，并用肩膀强行将门推开了一条缝。他把头伸进缝隙，看到一名男子躺在地板上，浑身是血。这名警官曾在迈阿密港工作，认出该男子就是蓝铃号的船长朱利安·哈维。调查人员拼凑出了哈维在前一天离开海岸警卫队总部后的行踪。他从停在附近的汽车里取出了一个手提箱，然后打车去了
Sandman Motel. At 11am he checked in using the false name of John Munro and said he was from Tampa. After going to his room, he hadn't been seen again. On a desk inside Harvey's motel room, investigators found a letter he had written to a friend. He mentioned nothing about the bluebell or what had happened to it, but wrote, I'm a nervous wreck and just can't continue. I'm going out now. I guess I either don't like life, or don't know what to do with it. After sealing the envelope, he wrote on it, cremate and bury at sea, before scribbling over the word cremate.
沙人汽车旅馆。上午11点，他用假名约翰·门罗办理了入住，并称自己来自坦帕。进入房间后，他就再也没有露面。在哈维旅馆房间的桌子上，调查人员发现了他写给朋友的一封信。信中只字未提蓝铃号或其遭遇，但写道：“我精神崩溃了，实在无法继续。我现在要走了。我想我要么是不喜欢生活，要么是不知道该拿它怎么办。”封好信封后，他在上面写道：“火化并海葬”，随后又涂掉了“火化”这个词。
Harvey had unpacked his suitcase, hung up his clothes, and left his suitcase on the luggage rack. He pinned a ten dollar note to his pillow as a tip for the cleaner. The blood on the bed suggested he'd first tried to suicide there before getting up and moving to the bathroom. He'd taken two photographs with him, one of his wife Mary and the other of his son from a previous relationship. These photos were found propped up on the toilet tank and were visible from the spot on the floor where Harvey died. He had used a razor blade to make multiple cuts in numerous places all over his body until he eventually bled out. Investigators were struck by the brutality of the scene. Harvey had been left mutilated by his many
哈维打开了手提箱，挂好了衣服，把手提箱留在了行李架上。他在枕头上别了一张十美元的钞票，作为给清洁工的小费。床上的血迹表明他最初试图在那里自杀，然后起身移到了浴室。他随身带了两张照片，一张是他妻子玛丽的，另一张是他与前一段关系中所生儿子的。这些照片被发现立在马桶水箱上，从哈维死亡的地板位置可以看到。他用剃须刀片在全身多处割了许多刀，直到最终失血过多而死。调查人员对现场的残酷程度感到震惊。哈维被他自己的许多
injuries. Friends suspected he had been left devastated and guilt ridden by the mass casualties on the Bluebell, including the loss of his wife. But this theory fell apart several days later when Terry Jo Duperrault was finally well enough to tell her story. Because Harvey had taken his own life before investigators had a chance to arrest him, no one would ever answer for what happened to the Bluebell and its passengers in a court of law. On Wednesday April 25 1962, the Coast Guard issued a detailed statement following a five-month-long investigation. They concluded that Captain Julian Harvey murdered his wife and three members of the
伤口弄得面目全非。朋友们怀疑他因蓝铃号上的大规模伤亡，包括失去妻子，而感到崩溃和内疚。但几天后，当特丽·乔·杜佩罗终于康复到可以讲述她的故事时，这一理论不攻自破。由于哈维在调查人员有机会逮捕他之前就自杀了，没有人会在法庭上为蓝铃号及其乘客的遭遇负责。1962年4月25日星期三，海岸警卫队在经过五个月的调查后发布了一份详细声明。他们得出结论，朱利安·哈维船长在凿沉蓝铃号之前，谋杀了他的妻子和三名
Dupereau family before scuttling the Bluebell. The miraculous survival of Terry Jo Dupereau was deemed to have been aided by several factors, including mild weather and the fact that a slick of oil from the sunken catch had enveloped the water around her lifeboat, deterring predators such as sharks. Terry Jo was also an outdoorsy child. At home in Wisconsin, she had played survival-themed games by herself in the woods that had in some small way prepared her for the plight she later faced. Terry Jo's ordeal led to the Coast Guard mandating that life rafts be bright orange instead of white to make them easier to spot amongst the ocean's
杜佩罗家族成员。特丽·乔·杜佩罗的奇迹生还被认为得益于多种因素，包括温和的天气，以及沉没帆船漏出的油膜覆盖了她救生筏周围的水域，从而阻挡了鲨鱼等掠食者。特丽·乔也是一个喜欢户外活动的孩子。在威斯康星州的家中，她曾独自在树林里玩过生存主题的游戏，这在某种程度上为她后来面临的困境做了准备。特丽·乔的磨难促使海岸警卫队强制要求救生筏必须是亮橙色而不是白色，以便在海洋的
whitecaps. After her recovery in hospital, TerryJo returned home to Green Bay, Wisconsin. She was raised by her aunt and uncle alongside her three cousins. People from all over the world who had been touched by her story sent her letters and gifts. The crew of the Captain Theo, the freighter that rescued her, even bought Terry Jo a life-sized doll after learning she'd lost one similar in the tragedy. When she was 12 years old, she changed her name to Terry, spelled T-E-R-E. She wanted to escape the name that was inextricably tied with an infamous crime and move beyond being seen as a victim. Changing her name allowed
白浪中更容易被发现。在医院康复后，特丽·乔回到了威斯康星州格林贝的家中。她由姑姑和姑父抚养长大，和三个表兄弟姐妹在一起。世界各地被她的故事所触动的人们给她寄来了信件和礼物。救起她的货船“西奥船长号”的船员在得知她在悲剧中丢失了一个类似的玩偶后，甚至给她买了一个真人大小的玩偶。12岁时，她将名字改成了特丽（Terry），拼写为T-E-R-E。她想逃离那个与臭名昭著的罪行紧密相连的名字，不再被视为受害者。改名让她
her to reclaim her identity and take some control back. Those around Terry never brought up the tragedy of what had happened to her family, so she learnt to avoid the subject as well. Almost two decades went by before Terry spoke about it. She married and had children without ever having opened up about her trauma. Eventually, she told a doctor what had happened, which gradually led to her being able to discuss it more openly. Sharing her story made her feel lighter, and eventually she co-wrote a book about the tragedy with survival expert Richard Logan. Titled Alone, Orphaned on the Ocean, the book is a detailed account of the crime, the subsequent events, and Terry's life after. In an interview about
能够重拾身份并夺回一些控制权。特丽周围的人从不提起她家人遭遇的悲剧，所以她也学会了回避这个话题。近二十年过去了，特丽才谈起这件事。她结婚并有了孩子，却从未敞开心扉谈论过她的创伤。最终，她告诉了一位医生所发生的一切，这逐渐使她能够更公开地讨论它。分享她的故事让她感到轻松了一些，最终她与生存专家理查德·洛根合著了一本关于这场悲剧的书。书名为《孤独，海洋中的孤儿》，详细记录了这起罪行、随后的事件以及特丽之后的生活。在一次关于
the book's publication with CBS News, Terry revealed that ever since what happened on the Bluebell, she has felt intuitively drawn to the water, and even pursued a career in water resources. Quote, "...Julian Harvey abandoned me thinking the ocean would swallow me, but instead it created a bond between me and water." In our book, I describe what it was like to be dependent on the water for the four days I waited to be rescued.
该书出版的CBS新闻采访中，特丽透露，自从蓝铃号事件发生以来，她直觉地被水所吸引，甚至从事了水资源方面的工作。引用：“……朱利安·哈维抛弃了我，以为海洋会吞噬我，但它反而在我与水之间建立了一种纽带。”在我们的书中，我描述了在等待获救的四天里，依赖水生存是什么感觉。
I write about the ocean life around me and the power of that experience. I went on to protect the water that had protected me as a little girl. Water is life and it is soothing for me to be on the beach. I find I can think clearly, relax, and feel closer to my lost family." Reflecting on the message she wanted to share with readers, Terry stated, "...I always believed I was saved for a reason, but it took me 50 years to gain the strength to be able to give other people hope with my story. If just one person goes on to heal from a life tragedy, my journey will have been worth it. I am a survivor trying to reach other survivors.
我写了关于我周围的海洋生物以及那种经历的力量。后来我保护了那个在我小时候保护过我的水。水就是生命，待在海滩上让我感到舒缓。我发现我可以清晰地思考、放松，并感觉离我失去的家人更近了。”在反思她想与读者分享的信息时，特丽说：“……我一直相信我获救是有原因的，但我花了50年才获得力量，能够用我的故事给其他人带来希望。如果只有一个人能从生活悲剧中治愈，我的旅程就是值得的。我是一个试图触及其他幸存者的幸存者。”
It took me so long, but I want people to understand that there is no timeline with healing. It is never too late. When 18-year-old Neya May went missing in 2002, her family did everything they could to help the police find her. But like so many missing persons cases, there comes a time when the leads dry up and there's nowhere left to look. At no point have we just got on with our lives. I heard something recently that really resonated. It was a woman from America who said that you never get over grief, you learn to move
我花了这么长时间，但我希望人们明白，治愈没有时间表。永远都不晚。当18岁的尼娅·梅在2002年失踪时，她的家人尽了一切努力帮助警方寻找她。但像许多失踪人口案件一样，总会有一个线索枯竭、无处可寻的时候。我们从未在任何时候就此继续我们的生活。我最近听到了一些真正引起共鸣的话。是一位美国女性说的，你永远无法克服悲伤，你学会了带着它
forward with it. And I was like, that's the best anyone's ever described it. Niamh's sister, Fionnuala, realised that a podcast might help find the answers the family was looking for. So for the past four years, I've been working with Niamh's family to take a closer look at the case. And what we found took us to places we never anticipated. Here's everything we've done. We've obviously got serious concerns about her welfare. I've just spoken to the last person to see her alive that we knew about and he's giving me a bullshit story.
继续前行。我当时想，这是任何人描述得最好的方式。尼娅的妹妹菲奥努拉意识到，播客可能有助于找到家人正在寻找的答案。因此，在过去的四年里，我一直与尼娅的家人合作，更深入地调查此案。我们发现的东西把我们带到了我们从未预料到的地方。这是我们所做的一切。我们显然对她的安危有严重的担忧。我刚刚和我们所知的最后一个见到她活着的人谈过，他在跟我胡说八道。
When I first started looking into this case in 2020, it was originally intended to be a single case file episode. But the more I looked, the more I found. So Steve, he's adamant that she never made it to Gokup Road. Stan is adamant that there's a credible sighting there. Nehems set out for a gap year after finishing high school to test her independence, but she never made it home. What happened in those final days?
当我2020年第一次开始调查这个案子时，它原本打算只做一集Casefile。但我调查得越多，发现的就越多。所以史蒂夫坚称她从未到达戈库普路。斯坦坚称那里有一个可信的目击记录。尼娅在高中毕业后开始了一年的间隔年，以测试她的独立性，但她从未回家。那些最后几天发生了什么？
And when the Blackhurst arrived, these two men got out. And as soon as I saw them and I saw that Blackhurst, I thought, they're bad baddies stay away from them. Mum called me and she said um look the police are investigating now and somebody claims that they dropped her off and she was hitchhiking. What started out as a potential case file episode turned into a 12-part series that took over four years to research. He didn't smile or anything, he just kind of looked empty and just like getting the
当布莱克赫斯特号到达时，这两个人下来了。我一看到他们，看到那辆布莱克赫斯特，我就想，他们是坏人，离他们远点。妈妈给我打电话说，嗯，你看警察现在正在调查，有人声称他们把她放下了，她当时在搭便车。原本可能成为一集Casefile的节目变成了一个12集的系列，花了四年多的时间进行研究。他没有笑什么的，他只是看起来很空洞，就像上车一样。
car. It was just kind of like aggressively like getting the car. Join me as we uncover what happened in Missing Nehiem, the new 12-part podcast series from Casefile Presents. Something that obviously woken me suddenly because I was disorientated. That's when I realised that there was just a cold, rough hand holding my hand because I had my hand over the edge of the bed and I could see the outline of somebody leaning over the bed.
就像是很有侵略性地上了车。加入我，让我们一起揭开《寻找尼娅》的真相，这是来自Casefile Presents的全新12集播客系列。有什么东西显然突然把我惊醒了，因为我感到迷失方向。就在那时，我意识到有一只冰冷、粗糙的手握着我的手，因为我的手放在床边，我可以看到有人弯腰趴在床上的轮廓。
Evil, I guess, has to be somewhat attractive, doesn't it? Otherwise, I wouldn't be able to sneak into every corner. So I whispered to my sister, I asked her if she was awake and she said yes. I said there's someone in the room and she said I know. Missing Nehiem will be available on September 24. Be sure to download and follow Missing Nehiem wherever you get your podcasts. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
我想，邪恶必须要有一定的吸引力，对吧？否则，它就无法潜入每一个角落。所以我对我姐姐耳语，问她是否醒着，她说是的。我说房间里有人，她说我知道。《寻找尼娅》将于9月24日上线。请务必在您获取播客的任何地方下载并关注《寻找尼娅》。本集目前还没有评论。点击转录中的任何句子即可发表评论。